في بارقه امل طبيه جديده نجح اطباء في
مساعده مريض بالسرطان ومصاب ايضا بالايدز
على التعافي من كلا المرضين المريض خضع
لعمليه زراع نخاع عضمي في المانيا ليصبح
ثالث حاله يعلن شفاؤها من فيروس نقص
المناعه البشريه مجله
نشرت تفاصيل معالجه الرجل الذي اطلق عليه
مرض دوسلد وهو الذي خضع لعمليه الزراعه
النخاع عظمي باستخدام خلايا جذعيه وفرتها
متبرعه تعاني طفره نادره في جين سي سي ار
5 هذه طفره تحد من دخول فيروس نقص المناعه
البشريه الى الخلايا والتحدي يكمن في
ايجاد متبرع يحمل مثل هذه الطفره الجينيه
تحديدا لكن علاج المريض شكل بحسب الاطباء
رؤيه مهمه تساهم في توجيه استراتيجيات
العلاج
زراعه نخاع العظم والخلايا الجذعيه عمليه
استبدال نخاع العظم للمريض بنخاع عظم جديد
يتم اخذه من متبرع او من المريض نفسه يمكن
المتبرع ان يتبرع بنخاعيه العظمي تحته
التخدير ويستغرق هذا الاجراء ساعه واحده
يتضمن جمع حوالي ربع لتر الى لتر واحد من
ماده تشبه الدم تستخدم هذه الطريقه لعلاج
امراض عده منها اورام الغدد اللمفاويه
وعدد من امراض السرطان كذلك فقر الدم كما
يوجد فرق بين عمليات زرع النخاع الشوكي
وزرع النخاع العظمي الاولى تستخدم عاده
لعلاج بعض الامراض الوراثيه بينما العظمي
لعلاج امراض الدم الخبيثه بحسب منظمه
الصحه العالميه فان هناك حوالي 50 الف
عمليه زرع نخاع العظم في جميع انحاء
العالم
كل عام
[موسيقى]
وبهذا الاجراء الطبي اي زراعه نخال عظم
استطاعت الطفل الرضيعه فيفا التعافي من
مرض سرطان الدم الليمفاوي الحاد او
لوكيميا والبطل المتبرع هنا هي اختها
نازيه التي تكبرها بثمانيه اعوام والتي
اثبتت التحاليل انها الانسب لاجراء هذه
العمليه استشاري امراض الدم والاورام
وزراعه نخاع العظم في المدينه الطبيه بابو
ظبي الدكتور زين العابدين قال ان زراعه
النخاع كانت سبيل الوحيد لانقاذ حياه
عفيفه وبعد ذلك خضعت الرضيعه لعنايه طبيه
صارمه لمراقبه استجابه جسمها للخلايا
الجديده ومع الملاحظه تم التحقق من نجاح
عمليه الزرع بنسبه 100%
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]